bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
on va tenter de comprendre ce qu'est une
échelle et comment on peut l'utiliser
alors vous imaginez bien quand j'ai une
carte ici dans la classe les ici une
carte de la belgique mais que la taille
de la belgique est beaucoup plus grande
dans la réalité ça je ne vous apprendrai
mais on ne fait pas non plus une carte
studio walt hors jeu sur une pierre
comme ça bah je vais j'ai tracé sa plus
ou moins et puis on va faire ça plus ou
moins comme ça il ya quand même une
rigueur à avoir on va représenter cette
carte
cette belgique miniature selon un
rapport à la réalité qui sera le même
pour toutes la carte
c'est à dire que on va réduire
on va faire une réduction comme une
photocopie on va réduire la belgique
dans les mêmes rapports pour toute la
carte sis à quelle échelle 1 voyez qu
ici
bagis à deux chiffres qui sont
mentionnés 1 800 milles mais ça veut
dire que ma carte et 800 mille fois plus
petite que la réalité ou la réalité si
vous voulez 800 mille fois plus grands
voiliers que pour toutes les cartes de
la classe ici on a une petite carte donc
évidemment la réalité et 2 millions de
fois plus grand et vrai que cette carte
avec que la carte va être petit plus les
chaînes bien sûr va être grand ici on a
une carte qui était encore plus petit
point de vue de sa représentation bas
c'est un 2 1 sur 2 millions 500 mille
voyez l'échelle c'est simplement un
rapport entre la et quand vous allez
faire une photocopie bas vous faites x 2
si vous voulez à grandir ici c'est la
même chose sauf qu'ici on fait divisée
en huit cent mille alors ça c'est une
première échelle on peut aussi retrouver
l'échelle sous cette forme voyez c'est
là c'est une échelle sous forme de
lignes michel une échelle l'ine donc
voilà si je mesure avec mon équerre la
distance je vois que 30 km est égal à 3
2 7 cm donc là j'ai un rapport de 800
mille fois un de 800000 donc
la carte huit cent mille fois plus
petite que la réalité mais quand je
mesure j'ai directement le rapport là
c'était plus facile parce que je sais
que avec mon équerre quand je mesurais
sur la carte plus ou moins quatre
centimètres ça fera plus ou moins 30 km
si je viens ici dans la région
saint-aubert leuze at voilà j'ai plus ou
moins quatre centimètres d'un voile je
sais que la louvière c'est plus ou moins
à 30 km de là
évidemment ce n'est pas très précis mais
ce n'est pas le but ainsi on veut être
très précis ben alors on va aller sur
google maps ça va être très facile ce
sera beaucoup plus et être calculé tout
ça ici c'est juste pour avoir un ordre
de grandeur quand on travaille sur les
cartes